I love this this outfit I've not seen
you dressed this way before
yeah I'm have kind of gone gebel today
which is um ghetto rebel ghetto rebel is
gay no sorry not like here I like your
necklace here I think so is my grandma's
handed down over the generations yeah
well I come from a family of
professional dog shows and so the word
[ __ ] is like used all the time is it
that's true your family actually does as
shows beagles and my great-grandmother
founded the beagle Club of Australia
uh-huh so so you grew up hearing the
word [ __ ] constantly yeah like you know
bring that [ __ ] over here that [ __ ]
looks fat stop feeding her and actually
I got you know a lot of trouble on my
very first day of kindergarten because I
looked at the teacher and said that
[ __ ] looks pregnant like five years old
I didn't go over so well did it no I
didn't I didn't think so
well let's let a lot to talk about here
as you said you are Australian you're
from Australia Sydney where are you from
um Sydney Sydney the western side which
is the more gangster side although we
didn't do drive-bys we just did drive
throughs
that's not quite as tough yeah with your
tough fighting beagle yeah do you uh you
I love your accent I love your
Australian accent I've noticed that in
this movie you you have an American
accent and I know I've seen you do an
American accent for you you're quite
good at it you're quite convincing oh
thanks that's a big compliment well how
do you perfect that how is it a hard
accent to get down the american accent
well basically I just pull my ear and
then like I totally start speaking
American if I want to get rid of it I'm
like two pulls and then down back to a
straight night I know I crikey you know
a lot of people like they're like oh how
do you do fully American me and I watch
a lot of reality shows which ones do you
watch um cuz like I want like a real
genuine American accent so what shows
like Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
I've been watching a lot of honey boo
boo
are you watching you do good yeah and
that's helping you got a bread mechanize
yeah and just because I really want my
accent to be authentic when I'm doing
babies yeah I do actually
you know seriousness like watch them and
just like repeat them when they talk and
then eventually you just hope by osmosis
so you will watch reality show and you
as they say their lines you just are
sitting there repeating staring yeah
look very crazy people I got a big hug
glitzy I'm gonna take my pig to the
pageant and I
yeah there's a copy of it if anyone
watch me do it they've got all that
girls now yeah that's very sad